[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
My name is Richard Vogg.
And I'm happy to be
here and talk about how
I became a Data Composer.
This ability of composing data
or creating data from scratch,
has been increasingly helpful
for me at my last job.
I was working for
a data analytics
company in Chile for the
last years and the client
that we were supporting
with analytics
was one of the largest
banks in the United States.
Similar to a music composer,
who assembles musical notes
and chords into
melodies and songs,
I started to play
around with data sets.
And using R, it's very
easy to get started.
It is fun to get
started as many of you
might also have experienced.
So for example it is very
easy to create a 1,000 random
normally distributed variables
and we can also easily create
variables from
other distributions
like the exponential
distribution
or we can create
categorical variables
by using the sample function.
We can combine all those
variables in a data frame
and then we have our
first, in this case,
nonsense data set ready.
And then we can go and
take a look at the data
and we can check
if what we compose
is actually what we wanted
to compose if it makes sense.
So I started to create small
melodies, small data melodies.
In the beginning because it
was fun and later because
it was useful.
I used the skill in
the business world
to improve the communication
with non-technical business
partners.
So I created small and easy
data sets and visualizations
about topics that the business
partners felt comfortable with.
And used them to
explain concepts,
explain methods and in general
to create a common ground
for discussion
and for questions.
When you compose a
song for your band,
it is not enough to
have a beautiful melody
for each one of the
instruments but you also
want them to sound
good together.
So in data words, we do not
only want independent variables
but we also want them to make
some sort of sense together.
And I trained that
skill and used it a lot
because we were working
with sensitive data.
So you could not just
send data to someone else
with a question.
But because not everyone
had the same level of access
to the data.
And instead I quickly
assembled a suitable data
set for each occasion and
was able to ask questions
but also to give advice without
having to see the real data
or having to touch
the real data.
Another application emerged
when we had more and more agile
projects.
So we had this aim
of having a working
deliverable in each iteration.
And this was sometimes
hard to reach
because we had to wait a
lot of time for the data.
So we had to talk to the
data owner, sometimes
request accesses, we
had to bring the data
into the right format.
And by using a
composed data set that
looked like the expected final
data set, we could already
start to work on the
output, on the report
and while we were still
waiting for the real data.
And in the end we
simply replaced
that composed data
set with the real data
set and improved the
whole process a lot.
When you want to
write a symphony,
you're not just aligning
a few instruments
but you have actually blocks
or groups of instruments that
have to sound good together.
And in data works that
could be a database,
where you have several
tables that are all
connected with each other.
And it is not easy to create a
complete database from scratch
but we still did it to
improve our internal courses.
So we wanted to make
those courses closer
to what we actually work with.
And we created a client
table, transaction table,
account tables and
combined all of them.
And made this whole database
available to everyone
in the company to
the internal courses
and also for small
prototypes and projects.
All this was about why data
composition is important.
Now how to compose with R?
There are of course
the distributions,
I already showed
in the beginning.
How easy it is to work
with a distribution
and there are also
a lot of functions
that can help you to correlate
your simulated data to create
those connections
between the variables.
There are functions
that help you to create
the relations between tables.
And of course, there are a
lot of packages out there,
that just wait to be
explored that can support you
on your data
composition process.
And as I just have
a few seconds left,
I wrote a blog post for each
one of those four points.
I invite you to visit my
blog and there are a lot more
details about those topics.
And I hope they might
be helpful for you
to become a data composer too.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[MUSIC PLAYING]